[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le 78 nous sommes le jeudi 21
décembre voici les titres une attaque de
plus a été commise envers le corps
enseignant mardi 19 décembre un élève du
collège Léonard de Vincy à é queevilleli
aurait tenté d'empoisonner l'une de ses
professeur avec un produit détergent
nous ferons le point sur cette possible
tentative d'empoisonnement dans quelques
instants le chef triplement étoilier
Christian lequer s'invite à la Maison
Fournaise de Chatou en collaboration
avec la chef du restaurant il revisite
des plats traditionnels boudin hachis
parmentier mousse au chocolat les
journalistes de la rédaction sont allés
les goûter et le jeudi comme d'habitude
nous vous donnerons nos idées de sorties
pour le weekend au programme de ce soir
concert de Jean-Michel jar au château de
versaill des comptes de Noël au château
de Breteuil ou encore un tour d'horizon
des patinoirs de Saint-Quentin en
iveline et puis les invités du 78 en
2uxè partie d'émission ce soir focus sur
la nouvelle pépite du tumbling Kevin
ferrira 20 ans a participeré au dernier
championnat du monde à Birmingham en
Angleterre il est licencié à l'USM des
clés sous-bois le sportif sera en
plateau avec son coach René
etbami et voilà pour le programme de ce
soir tout de suite on fait le point sur
les informations du jour à retenir dans
les
ivelines et on commence avec vous
Gabriel Gontier donc je le disais tout à
l'heure dans les titres mardi dernier un
goûté de fin d'année dans le collège à
éceville à vira la catastrophe oui tout
à fait Régine un élève de 3e a versé du
détergent mélangé à une boisson sucrée à
sa professeur d'art plastique
l'enseignante du collège Léonard de
Vincy s'est rapidement senti mal
hospitalisée elle est sortie mercredi de
l'hôpital et a repris les cours ce matin
elle a déposé plainte contre l'élève à
l'origine de l'empoisonnement un élève
avec qui elle avait eu une altercation
le jour de l'incident une enquête a été
ouverte et le jeune homme a avoué dans
la matinée ce qui l'a qualifié être une
mauvaise blague Julien Leroi s'est rendu
auprès des collégiens de l'établissement
on écoute leur réaction c'est pas bien
de faire ça une prof qui qui nous
enseigne des trucs qui veut nous aider à
progresser dans la vie de tous les jours
je pense que c'est pas bien et aussi il
y a en ce moment en France il y a ça
arrive à beaucoup de professeurs des
agressions comme ça et en ce moment
c'est pas normal que ça tout ça tout ça
c'est choquant un peu et en plus la prof
elle était pas méchante ou quoi donc
elle était là depuis 2 ans ça fait 2 ans
qu'on est ici nous donc on la connaî en
vrai elle était pas méchante ENF elle
elle était stricte quand il fallait mais
elle était pas méchante quoi et nous
avons appris en fin d'après-midi que
deux collégiens ont été placés en garde
à vue pour tentative d'empoisonnement et
complicité et région île-de-fance aide
les villes particulièrement touchées par
les émeutes de cet été dans les ivelines
oui six communes ivelinoises vont
bénéficier d'une enveloppe pour faire
face aux dégâts engendrés par les
émeutes de l'été l'été dernier à la
suite de la mort de Naël les villes de
manel jolie la verrière poissie
Chantelou Lévin Fontenis lefleuri ou
encore Sartrouville avait subi des
dégradations importantes une enveloppe
globale d'1,6 million d'euros va être
envoyée par la région cette somme ne
correspond pas à une subvention pur mais
à des avances remboursables selon nos
confrères de cette suctu et pour
anticiper sereinement les départs pour
les vacances de fin d'année vous nous
faites un point bisonfuté oui car le
trafic s'annonce difficile pour vos
départs en vacances bisonfuté voie rouge
dans le sens des départs pour les
journées de vendredi et samedi il est
conseillé de partir avant 10h en évitant
l'autoroute à 10 le vendredi si vous
prenez la route samedi mieux vaut se
déplacer avant 6h du matin et comp
tourner l'autoroute à 13 pour le
réveillon les départs s'annoncent plutôt
calme enfin dimanche bisonfuté annonce
vert dans le sens des retours et bien
merci Gabriel pour ses conseils et
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous êtes
témoin d'une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous le partager en le mettant sur les
hashtag 78 new sur les réseaux
sociaux et on continue toujours avec
vous Gabriel vous êtes sur tous les
fronts ce soir on continue notamment
avec le conseil d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin en evening qui s'est tenu
la semaine dernière quels sont les
points à retenir et bien premier point
important Régine celui de la National 10
notamment l'enfouissement de la route au
niveau de trappe l'enquête publique date
de fin 2016 et les travaux vont
s'étendre de 2024 à 2029 alors les élus
ont évoquer le financement l'État a revu
sa copie de plus de 56 % passant de
95000 à 149 millions d'euros de travaux
pour cet enfouissement financé également
par la Région le Département
l'agglomération de 50 ans en iveline et
la commune de trappe on écoute le
conseiller communautaire délégué à la
voirie et aux grands travaux les cinq
partenaires ont décidé de de remonter
leur participation au prorata du
pourcentage auquel sur lesquel il s'est
engagé ce qui pour Saint-Quentin fait
une augmentation de 76 million d'euros
quand même donc augmentation très
conséquente alors que l'on suit parce
que le projet pour nous important et
surtout on le suit pour une autre raison
également c'est que ce projet nous
permet d'obtenir de l'État un engagement
sur le projet de malmedon le le
carrefour un peu plus loin qui lui est
au rond-point de Mora coignière et la
verrière avec aussi un projet
d'enfouissement plus modeste qu'on
parler d'une vingtaine de millions
d'euros mais quand mêmealement très
important pour permettre un accès direct
à la gare autre point important à
retenir de ce conseil Régine
d'agglomération pardon qui ça concerne
la Promopole le rapport d'activité des
comptes de 2022 de la société d'économie
mixte était présenté la pépinière
d'entreprise située à Montini le
breteneux à un taux d'occupation au-delà
des 95 % les comptes ont été approuvés
lors de ce conseil on écoute Hotman
nasrou conseiller communautaire de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline je rappelle que
la structure est aujourd'hui totalement
désendettée il n'y a aucune dette
aujourd'hui portée par la pépinière
d'entreprise et au contraire nous avons
un chiffre d'affaires positif et un
résultat qui est positif nous avons
atteint l'an dernier le million d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires c'est un record
dans l'histoire de Promopole et un
bénéfice net donc qui qui se confirme
d'une année sur l'autre c'est donc une
structure saine qui rend un service au
territoire en accueillant des petites
entreprises des jeunes entreprises de
manière modulable et avec tout un
ensemble d'accueil et de services qui
sont proposés sur la pépinière et donc
on est très heureux de ce travail que
nous avons pu faire avec l'agglomération
de canta en Yveline et enfin il y avait
également une délibération sur l'île de
loisirs de 50 ans en Yveline oui pendant
près d'un heure les élus ont parlé de la
gestion de la plus grande base de
loisirs d'Île-de-France avec ses 6 an
600 hactares d'espace vert et ses 8000
visiteurs annuels ils ont approuvé le
retrait de l'agglomération du syndicat
mixte d'études d'aménagement et de
gestion de l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline cette décision
fait notamment suite à des tensions sur
la gouvernance de la structure le
département des Yvelines a décidé de
quitter cette année le conseil
d'administration de l'île de loisirs 50
ans Eveline ne veut plus supporter le
déficit de la structure qui s'élève en
moyenne à un peu plus d'un million de
d'un million d'euros annuel bien merci
Gabriel pour ces précisions on vous
retrouvera tout à l'heure he de nouveau
pour vos sorties du weekend et puis on
va maintenant parler de Noël hein le
réveillon approche à grand pas et le
saumon fumé et la truite sont des
produits phardes de nos repas de fête
installés dans le Nord desésivine la
pisculture de Villette est en
effervescence poisson entier tranché ou
en conserve la palette de choix est
exhaustive un reportage de Julien
Leroi des gestes précis et rapides à
quelques jours des fêtes de fin d'année
cinq trancheurs de la pisculture de
Villette s'affire pour préparer les
saumons saler fumer pendant 24 heures et
tranché sur place un rythme soutenu pour
satisfaire un carnet de commande bien
rempli plus de la moitié de la
production annuelle de ces poissons est
réalisé durant le mois de décembre on
fume euh au moins 50 kg par semaine
toute l'année et en ce moment évidemment
c'est plutôt 50 kg par jour suivant le
la taille du saumon on va faire des
tranches plus ou moins grandes et puis
on va les calibrer par exemple là je
suis en train de les calibrer à 45 g
pour faire des tranches pas trop grosses
ce qui permet de faire des plaques de 10
tranches par exemple qui sont pas trop
copieuses le saumon provient des îles
ferroé en Europe du Nord contrairement à
la truite ce produit phare de la
pisculture de Villette est élevé sur
place dans ces bassins de plus de 120
ans nourri principalement à base
d'insectes on retrouve ici des variétés
comme la truite AR cel fario ou jaune
nous allons un matin les abattre ces
poissons sont très rapidement dans les
minutes qui suivent évicéré au ciseaux
ensuite plongé dans de l'eau salée donc
une saumure pendant quelques heures et
ensuite suspendu à un crochet en inox et
accroché à des gris qui vont en chambre
froide pour se reposer pendant minimum
24 heures pour que la chair se détende
dans ce grand four 240 truites sont
fumées grâce à cette sure de bois de
être une cuisson d'une heure à 150° plus
de 2000 sachets de S produit sont conçus
pour les fêtes une activité réalisée sur
le site depuis 1947 je prends le poisson
le plus gros et la petite astuce ça va
être d'aller voir à cœur s'il reste du
sang et si le sang est cuit ou pas je
vais essayer de décoller gentiment la
colonne vertébrale de la
chair on voit le long de la colonne
vertébrale un liseret légèrement
marronné ce qui veut dire que le sang à
cœur du poisson a été cuit dans la
vallée de la veau couleur la pici
culture de Villette est installée depuis
1896 poisson entiers tranchés en riette
ou en soupe de nombreux articles sont
disponibles dans la boutique sur place
compteter 82 € le kilo pour des tranches
de saumon fumé et 4,80 € pièces pour une
truite fumée de 150 g de quoi combler
les papis des convives les plus
exigeants durant vos repas de
fête allez comme chaque jeudi c'est
l'heure d'ouvrir une page
loisir
[Musique]
et je vous propose de rester sur la
thématique culinaire je le disais tout à
l'heure dans les titres Christian lequer
chef cuisinier triplement étoilé du
Palace le George 5 à Paris collabore sur
la nouvelle carte du restaurant La
Maison Fournaise à Chatou Mathilde
Francou et vous Gabrielle contier êtes
parti savourer ces nouveaux plats
regardez
[Musique]
le chef triplement étoilé Christian
Lesquer icône de la haute gastronomie
parisienne s'invite à la Maison
Fournaise de Chatou depuis octobre il
collabore avec la chef actuelle Hima el
berimi il réinvente la carte ensemble je
vous propose qu'on a découvrir tout
ça sit tué en bord de scène la Maison
Fournaise est chargée d'histoire créée
en
1857 les peintres impressionnistes
Pissaro de gars ou encore Renoir sont
venus manger ici Auguste Renoir a
d'ailleurs représenté le lieu dans son
fameux tableau le déjeuner des canottier
et depuis 166 ans l'esprit est resté le
même on y retrouve une impression de
guinguette parisienne et en ce mardi
midi les clients sont nombreux j'aime le
cadre j'aime l'endroit euh et puis
l'histoire du lieu aussi c'est important
l'environnement est agréable et puis la
cuisine est délicieuse je viens très
régulièrement dans ce dans ce superbe
restaurant et je je découvre pour la
première fois le nouveau chef et la
nouvelle carte et je suis absolument
fasciné par la qualité des ma la
présentation on y vient depuis très
longtemps moi ça fait 30 ans que je
connais cette maison alors je conseille
aux gens qui veulent venir manger les
ravioles elles sont très bonnes
Christian Lesquer est le chef du
restaurant Le au sein du palace parisien
for season George 5 grâce à cette
nouvelle collaboration avec la chef Hima
elberimi de nouveaux plats sont à la
carte comme le boudin à la passion ou la
mousse au chocolat je crois
qu'aujourd'hui je ce qui est très bien à
mon niveau c'est de d'expliquer de
transmettre un peu on va dire l'art de
vivre dans une petite maison
particulière qui est quand même une
maison bourgeoise entre parenthèses et
se de donner de donner un peu de de peps
dans la cuisine les deux chefs mettent
également à l'honneur les produits de
saison et favorisent le circuit court et
le terroir francilien pour la chef
Hakima elberimi cette collaboration est
une obè apprendre le le bon manière de
travailler la bonne cuisine française ça
fait vraiment un grand grand plaisir de
travailler avec le chef comme chef
Christian
[Musique]
Oscar bonne AFF ma merci c'est l'heure à
présent de déguster pour l'entrée j'ai
suivi les conseils des clients fidèles
et j'ai pris les ravioles de langoustine
en plat le coquelet grillé et en dessert
la surprenante mousse au chocolat tiède
pour un montant total de 64 € la Maison
Fournaise démontre que la haute
gastronomie peut être accessible car le
restaurant propose aussi des menus
allant de 29 à 36 € à la fin du service
c'est aussi l'heure du verdict pour les
clients c'était excellent tout était
excellent vraiment faut pas mettre 20/
20 parce que sinon il y a plus de marge
de progression alors je vais dire entre
18 et 19 sur
[Musique]
20 alors si vous aussi vous voulez
tester le restaurant La Maison Fournaise
sachez qu'il est ouvert tous les jours
sauf le lundi allez bon
appétit et on poursuit cette page loisir
avec vos idées de sortie Gabriel quel
est le programme pour ce weekend de Noël
et bien j-3 avant Noël Régine et
plusieurs sorties ont retenu mon
attention pour ce weekend on commence
avec un concert unique au château de
Versailles pour le 25 décembre l'auteur
compositeur Jean-Michel jar investit la
célèbre galerie des Glaces je vous
parleris d'un concert unique pourquoi
car il s'agit d'un concert immersif ceux
qui ne pourront pas assister
physiquement pourront le découvrir dans
le métaverse grâce à une colleexion en
réalité virtuelle dans ce spectacle le
musicien rendra hommage aux grandes
fêtes royales mais aussi aux innovations
technologiques on regarde un extrait de
la bande
[Musique]
annonce au c'est 600 spectateurs qui
sont attendus en physique et pour ceux
Régine qui veulent y assister à distance
et qui sont moins à l'aise avec le
métaverse rendez-vous sur W9 où le
concert sera retransmis en tout cas de
quoi danser toute la soirée du 25
décembre et même potentiellement de
redécouvrir la galerie des Glaces sous
toute une autre une autre forme alors on
part maintenant direction rambouillé ou
un autre rendez-vous nous attend ce
weekend oui ça se passe au musée
rambolit train vous qui vous propose un
voyage de Noël no pour le 23 décembre au
programme de ces animations festives
compte de Noël suivi d'une visite du
musée une plongée dans le monde du train
miniature qui pourrait aider les petits
et les grands à patienter encore un peu
jusqu'au soir de Noël à noter également
que les 27 et 28 décembre ainsi que les
3 et 4 janvier le musée vous propose de
monter à bord de son train de jardin
spécial Noël de quoi prolonger les fêtes
exactement et une autre activité de
saison pourrait également faire
patienter avant le réveillon plusieurs
patinoirs vous ouvrent leurs porte en ce
moment oui en intérieur ou en extérieur
plusieurs communes ont installé des
patinoirs pour les fêtes en voici une
liste non exhaustive au clés sous-bois
vous pouvez chausser vos patins dans
l'espace Philippe Noiré où une patinoire
est installée jusqu'au 6 janvier attrape
c'est une patinoire de 288 m de 288 m²
qui vous attend jusqu'au 5 janvier avec
plusieurs soirées à thème proposé pour
les familles ou encore pour les ados
enfin cette année encore une patinoire
extérieure vous attend dans votre centre
commercial de l'espace Saint-Quentin
elle est accessible jusqu'au 6 janvier
et desès samedis le château de Breteuil
propose lui aussi des animations pour
les fêtes de fin d'année si vous
souhaitez découvrir ou redécouvrir le
château de Breteuil c'est le moment
Régine pour les fêtes le monument a
revêtu ses plus belles décorations sapin
table de fête ou encore façade et jardin
illuminé le château des conttes de Péro
et fééic en plus des visites commenter
des comptes de Noël seront proposés ce
weekend et on termine avec un parcours
d'art lumineux à Mantel jolie oui que
diriez-vous de redécouvrir la ville
illuminée c'est en tout cas l'objectif
de l'événement lueur de manthe dans un
parcours au travers de la commune la
ville de mont-elajolie vous propose une
visite nocturne de son patrimoine
illuminé de scénographies lumineuses et
d'œuvrees d'art numérique pour réaliser
ses installations des artistes nationaux
et internationaux ont été réunis uni
parmi les lieux à découvrir
l'incontournable collégial bien sûr mais
aussi l'hôtel de ville ou encore la
place du marché Aublé vous avez jusqu'au
10 février 2024 pour profiter du
spectacle bien merci Gabriel vous avez
une préférence pour ce weekend ah le
concert à la galerie desgass je pense
que ça peut être sympa très original moi
je dirais plutôt la pâtinoire ça fait un
petit moment que j'ai pas testé
j'aimerais bien voir ce que je VO allez
on prend maintenant la direction de
Chevreuse jusqu'au 14 avril le musée
gratalou exposera les œuvres inédites de
l'artiste polonais Ladislas kizno ce
peintre connu pour ses œuvres sur papier
froissé les explications de Mathilde
Francou le musée gratalou est situé en
plein cœur du village de Chevreuse il
expose les grandes œuvres du peintre Guy
Rachel gratalou mais aussi les grands
artistes qui ont créé l'art cont orin
dans les années 50 et 60 comme Ladislas
Kino c'est un artiste immense c'est un
artiste très utonnant d'une période un
petit peu particulière qu'on appelle la
peinture informelle la peinture
informelle c'est finalement de la
peinture qui n'est ni abstraite ni
figurative c'est une peinture à lui et
lui encore c'est quelqu'un cétait un
créateur un créateur Ladislas Kino en
était bien un puisque c'est lui qui a
inventé le concept du froissage dans les
années 40 lorsque l'artiste n'était pas
content de ses dessins il les froissait
et les mettait dans sa poche un jour en
ressortant un de ces brouillons il s'est
dit qu'il fallait en faire une œuvre
d'art il faut savoir une chose c'est que
Kino c'est aussi l'ancêtre c'est c'est
le précurseur du street art c'est lui
qui le premier à tagué ces toile hein
donc vous avez ici cette œvre boudatag
qui à la fois exprime cette technique
nouvelle qui était effectivement de
taguer de maltraiter ces toile Ladislas
Kino était aussi un peintre engagé à
travers son art son contemporain le
célèbre Picasso a même dit de lui
souciez-vous de Ladislas Kino qui ne
froise pas que des papiers c'est un
artiste
[Musique]
puissant et puis dans le jardin on
présente justement des artistes vivants
et talentueux et je vous emmène voir
Laurette sucar Laurette sucar est une
artiste pluridisciplinaire elle est à la
fois poétesse plasticienne et éditrice
de livre dans le jardin du musée elle a
recopié ses poèmes sur deux de ses
œuvres des livres d'artistes ouverts et
des grands rouleaux vous voyez le poème
est écrit sur ses rouleaux volumain hein
vous pouvez les deviner à
travers cette transparence et ce travail
de peinture absolument superbe pour les
plus curieux chaque œuvre présenté et
documenté par un podcast cette
exposition est ouverte jusqu'au 14 avril
[Musique]
2024 et si vous nous suivez sur les
réseaux sociaux vous avez sans doute vu
passer notre calendrier de l'avant
yvelinois chaque jour un journaliste de
la rédaction de tv78 propose une idée de
cadeau 100 % locale gourmandise visite
ou encore expérience à vivre dans notre
département je vous propose qu'on ouvre
ensemble la case d'aujourd'hui sapeur
pompier un métier qui fait toujours
rêver dans notre calendrier de l'avent
de tv78 je vous propose aujourd'hui un
ouvrage qui parle de la profession au
plus
[Musique]
petit à la caserne au cœur d'une
intervention le livre animés des
pompiers transportent les jeunes
lecteurs dans le quotidien des soldats
du feu quel matériel embarquent-il dans
leur camion comment se protègeent-t-il
du feu Sébastien frébon sapeur pompier
professionnel des Yvelines et Anne
Sophie Boman répondent à toutes ces
questions en image dans cet ouvrage je
vous découvrirez 20 animations pour
habiller les pompiers déplacer des
engins ou encore déployer la grande
échelle et même un pop-up qui permet de
voir une scène de feu en trois
dimensions on y trouve aussi des petites
fiches pour sensibiliser les enfants aux
accidents de la voie publique et aux
incendies domestiques le livre animé des
pompiers est édité chez tourbillon et
est disponible au prix de 12,90
€ allez c'est bientôt l'heure des
invités du 78 mais juste avant je vous
propose de jeter un coup d'œil à la mé
de
[Musique]
demain demain matin le ciel sera couvert
sur l'ensemble du territoire il faudra
s'attendre également à quelques averses
du côté de Mantel jolie Versailles et
Rambouillet les températures seront
plutôt dou au-dessus des normales de
saison en moyenne 10°gr sur tout le
territoire et pas de changement
l'après-midi le ciel restera gris il
fera entre 10 et
12°gr pour les prévisions météo de ce
weekend samedi le soleil fera tout de
même quelques apparitions avec des
éclaircis sur tout le département il
fera entre 8 et
12°gr dimanche la grisaille fera son
grand retour au niveau des températures
météo France prévoit une légère hausse
il fera entre 9 et
13°gr allez c'est l'heure à présent de
passer aux invités du
[Musique]
78 et on va maintenant parler de
tumbling un sport de gymnastique
acrobatique et ce soir sur le plateau
nous sommes accompagnés de l'une des
pépites du moment Kevin ferrira bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous avez 20 ans vous êtes
licencié à l'USM des clés sous-bois et
vous êtes arrivé 16e en 16e position au
championnat du monde à Birmingham en
novembre dernier aujourd'hui vous êtes
accompagné de votre coach donc René
etbami bonsoir bonsoir alors vous suivez
Kevin ferra depuis déjà voilà 5 6 ans
effectivement alors aujourd'hui alors
c'était votre première participation
donc au championnat du monde senior vous
étiez classé à la 19e place l'an dernier
et cette année vous êtes 16e vous avez
gagné donc trois places votre sentiment
aujourd'hui bah tout d'abord moi je
pensais pas aller aussi haut pour les
championnats du monde
c'était histoire dire de bah participer
et puis bah profiter à fond et au final
bah j'ai réussi à qualifier la France au
jeu mondiaux et très heureux c'est très
fier pour vous également j'imagine bien
sûr comme il vient de le préciser en
fait l'objectif pour l'équipe de France
Ctait de parce que notre meilleur
Français qui vient d' cl également est
actuellement blessé rture t donc très
grosse blessure il n'a pas pu participer
à à cette compétition qui était
qualificative pour les Jeux mondiaux
parce que notre sport n'est pas
olympique et c'est les Jeux mondiaux qui
remplacent cette compétition il fait
gagner en quotat et Kevin nétait pas pas
son objectif et et il a fait la
compétition de de sa vie à ce niveau-là
et donc du coup il a réussi à qualifier
alors qu'on comptait pas sur lui à
qualifier la France au je mondiaux donc
c'était c'est vraiment une une
performance historique pour lui fallit
être dans les huit premières nations
voilà voilà pas mal alors justement donc
c'était compétition votre vie quel
souvenir est-ce que vous en gardez
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on retient
quand on fait aucun stress euh les
personnes là-bas sont super sympa et
puis c'est les les décorations tout en
fait ça a rien à voir avec la France
c'est les tout ce qui est comment dire
pour euh j'ai j'ai pas les mots vous
avez pas les mots c'est peut-être
l'émotion aussi non c'est non mais c'est
franchement c'est beau tout est bien
fait toute l'organisation est
magnifique c'est un souvenir aussi pour
vous que vous garderez en tête j'imagine
bien sûr parce que je pense que n'ayant
pas d'objectif réel il est été là-bas
pour se faire plaisir il a pris plaisir
sur la piste ça s'est vue et il a fait
la série qui n'a jamais réalisé même à
l'entraînement même à l'entraînement
parce que il on pensait qu'ilé au
qualification il était en demi-finale et
en demi-finale on s'est regardé on a dit
mais cétait pas prévu on fait quoi et là
il' on s'est dit ben vas-y fais cette
série que tu n'as jamais fait évidemment
une série qui dans ses cordes mais qui
n' jamais réalisé donc je pense qu'
s'est dit de toute façon je n'ai rien à
perdre là c'est que du du bonheur du
bonus et donc il a fait sa série voilà
sans pression et il a fait une très très
belle série voilà alors juste pour
revenir sur ce sport qui est le tumbling
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
d'où vous vient cette pass
alors moi de base je faisais pas du tout
ce sport je faisais de la gym dans un
club qui justement avait du Tumling mon
entraîneur malheureusement s'était fait
virer et en attendant pour éviter une
grosse pause il y avait le tomling et
mon mon père m'a proposé d'essayer le
Tumling très franchement je voulais pas
du tout j'étais bien lancé sur la gym et
au final bah je suis amoureux du Tumling
et vous avez du coup commencé à quel âge
j'ai commencé à l'âge de 13 14 ans 13 14
14 c'est tard pour c'est tard tard plus
13 ans ou donc aujourd'hui très belle
performance quelqu'un qui n'avait pas
cette ambition en tout cas ça ben c'est
c'est génial alors pourquoi est-ce que
vous vous pratiquez le tumbling aux clés
sousbis alors vers chez moi il y a pas
de salle approprié enfin pour pour les
les termes pour tout ce qui est distance
il faut des réglementations par exemple
la piste fait 5 m la course deélan entre
10 et 11 m et la réception 6 m et nous
en fait il y a pas de gymnase qui
pourrait accepter ça vers chez moi
malheureusement est-ce que vous habitez
où exactement vers draveille enfin
draveille 91210 ah oui donc ça ça me
fait une trotte ça fait une pe une
petite trotte alors dans ce club il y a
aussi Axel duriz qui est également une
pépite quelles sont vos relations
aujourd'hui c'est mon meilleur ami W
malheureusement il est pas là avec nous
ce soir mais ça aurait été un grand
plaisir et alors vous êtes aussi donc
qualifié pour ces prochains Mondiaux qui
se tiendront en Chine aujourd'hui sur
quelle progression est-ce que vous
pourrez travailler continuer à fond sans
sans de sans stress et puis essayer de
rattraper mon mon meilleur ami avoir le
même niveau un jour ça serait pas mal
concurrence quand même entre vous deux
oui ah bien sûr ça c'est quand même mais
bon toujours dans la gentilless et René
du coup les objectifs quels sont les
objectifs pour le club pour le club
c'est ben qu'il confirme sa place parce
que là il est donc s il s'est qualifié
pour les pour pour être en équipe de
France maintenant il y a les
championnats d'Europe qui sont au mois
d'avril au Portugal à Guimares et donc
l'objectif c'est qu'il reconfirme que ce
n'est pas un hasard qu'il est en équipe
de France et donc il faut qu'il se r
sélectionne pour les prochains
championnats d'Europe qui sont dans dans
dans 3 mois c'est pas c'est pas un
hasard mais finalement est-ce que vous
aussi vous n'y êtes pas pour quelque
chose hein de toutes ces réussites euh
je n'aime pas trop parler de moi c'est
vrai que je suis un je suis un grand
passionné euh je pense que je tombe sur
des pépites aussi c'est en fait c'est un
échange entre l'athlète et moi
c'est-à-dire c'est moi j'ai j'ai une
part de enfin de dans dans son résultat
lui également il a une part et je pense
que c'est la connexion des deux des deux
personnes qui font que ben on peut
aboutir à si on on regarde dans la même
direction en général ça paye en général
donc moi je suis un grand passionné de
tomling je leur transmet la passion ils
sont des passionnés puis on les
objectifs on les fixe ensemble et à part
moment où ils sont fixés ensemble en
général ça marche en général voilà c'est
plutôt complémentaire c'est un plaisir à
la fois pour vous et pour bien sûr bien
sûr c'est ah si non je le ferai pas
c'est vraiment un plaisir de voil c'est
je ne dis pas que je pourant c'est mon
métier mais rarement je vais travailler
je dis je vais entraîner donc ça dit
tout et donc de nouveaux objectifs pour
l'année prochaine donc vous dit
championnat d'Europe pour lui et j'ai un
petit jeune aussi Thiago via qui est
junior donc championnat d'Europe senior
et Junior c'est la même semaine donc
pour le petit aussi qui soit en équipe
de France junior là on aura gagner
quelque chose quoi et bien merci Kevin
ferrira et René etbami bien nous en tout
cas on continuera à vous suivre dans
votre parcours et d'ailleurs on vous
souhaite le meilleur et c'est également
la fin de ce 78 je vous remercie pour
cette fidélité je vous souhaite de
passer une excellente soirée sur tv78 et
bien sûr de passer un excellent
réveillon de
[Musique]
Noël